[Музика]
привіт знову ласкаво просимо на урок англійської мови
мене звати Наталія давайте давайте почнемо,
тому ми продовжимо розмову про спорт і
давайте перевіримо домашнє завдання Я попросив вас
заповнити таблицю про спортивне
обладнання та людей, тож давайте перевіримо  подивіться
я хороша дівчина я підготувала
для вас усі відповіді, тож давайте назвемо всі
слова так що крикет повторюйте за мною
крикет крикет сокира бита давайте
з наступним легка атлетика кросівки
боксер боксер боксерські рукавички сніг чистий
сніг  колір гідрокостюм
хокей хокеїст ковзани і парк
футбол футболіст футбольний
сноубордист сноубордист сноуборд добре,
тому, як ви бачите хокей, у нас немає
спеціального слова для людини, яка грає в
хокей, ми просто називаємо його
хокеїстом або  якщо з контексту зрозуміло,
що ви говорите про
хокей, ви можете просто сказати гравець, давайте
подивимося на снорклінг, наприклад,
є слово колір снігу або
сноубордист, зараз я хотів би  ви
подумайте над дуже цікавим словом
йога, то дозвольте мені записати
назву спорту це йога що нам потрібно для
йоги чи пам'ятаєте ви
m-net, молодець, то напишіть це тут
Аміт ми також можемо згадати одяг,
який нам потрібен  для футболки yoga Legends нам
не потрібні кросівки, зазвичай ви просто
носите шкарпетки або босоніж, але
як щодо людини, яка займається йогою,
ми називаємо це йоґом, це цікаві
слова йога йоґ, йоґ, займається йогою,
це дивовижно, так  повторюйте за мною йог
знову йоги молодець і речення
йог займається йогою і давайте додамо
обладнання йог займається йогою на килимку або
за допомогою килимка давайте спробуємо зі сноубордистом
скажімо, сноубордист кататися на сноуборді,
використовуючи сноуборд, добре зроблено давайте спробуємо з
футболіст футболіст грає у футбол,
використовуючи футбол цікавий і Mr.
Іго — боксер, боксер займається боксом
у боксерських рукавичках. Одягнув боксерські
рукавички, добре, тепер давайте йти далі
, подивіться на картинку, що ви бачите,
я бачу хлопчиків і дівчаток.
тому я бачу слова в Японії, які проводяться після
спортивного дня в Японії, тож, ймовірно,
це японці або милі діти Депа,
правда, що вони роблять, тому що ви бачите, що
вони штовхають ці величезні м’ячі, так що це
виглядає
як змагання, і якщо ми подивимося на
назвіть день здоров’я та спорту в Японії, тож
це, ймовірно, спортивні змагання,
щоб зберегти здоров’я дітей, а тепер давайте
подумаємо над двома питаннями, які ви
хотіли б знати про цей текст про
день здоров’я та спорту в Японії, два
запитання,
тож, ймовірно, дата, коли це було  вони починають
добре проводити цей спортивний день, тому давайте
запишемо його номер один – це побачення та
які дії правильно, що
вони роблять, про що йде мова, зараз
давайте послухаємо текст, прочитаємо
текст і спробуємо знайти відповідь  rs для
цих двох питань давайте підемо до
дня здоров’я та спорту в Японії від
Kokichi Oh No
[Музика]
тут, в Японії, ми дуже захоплюємося спортом
, насправді у нас навіть є національне свято,
щоб відзначити нашу любов до спорту,
воно називається днем здоров’я та спорту  і це
відбувається щороку в другий
понеділок жовтня
японці святкують цей день з 1966 року. Він
відзначає відкриття літніх
Олімпійських ігор у Токіо за два роки до цього в
1964 році в День здоров'я та спорту, у більшості
шкіл проводиться щорічний день поля.
учні міні-олімпіади змагаються в
командах і беруть участь у різноманітних
подіях.
Мені завжди подобався польовий день у моїй
школі, і цей рік був нічим іншим:
день розпочався з параду всіх
команд, а потім усі учасники розійшлися
по всій  поле для групової розтяжки
протягом дня ми змагалися в багатьох
традиційних легкоатлетичних змаганнях, таких як
спринт на сто метрів і
стрибки в довжину, але ми також проводили кілька унікальних японських
ігор, наприклад, у  Великі команди епохи Тама
мають дві-три хвилини, щоб кинути
якомога більше маленьких мішків з квасолею
в кошик на вершині високого стовпа, а
в атомних командах або командах Агассі по двоє повинні
котити гігантський м’яч через смугу
перешкод і спортивний день.  Це не лише
для дітей, це сприяє активному способу життя
для людей різного віку, насправді
в моїй школі були спеціальні події для батьків,
також мій тато не брав участь у змаганнях,
тому що у нього боліла голова, але я думаю,
що це був лише привід цілий
день  було дуже весело. Я не можу дочекатися
наступного року
[Музика],
тож давайте подивимося на ці два питання,
перше було про дату, коли ми
маємо цей день здоров’я та спорту в Японії,
чи знайшли ви інформацію в тексті
правильно  скажімо, це почалося в 1966 році і коли
вони проводять, вони проводять у
другий понеділок жовтня, так що в другий
понеділок жовтня, а що щодо діяльності,
чим вони зазвичай займаються, так це схоже на
міні-Олімпіаду, відповідно до
тексту, вони називають це днем поля  що таке a
На полі Паула, так багато команд, вони
змагаються в різних
видах діяльності, тому у них є багато подій та
різних ігор, тому тут це було згадано
в тексті про команду atomic або Agassi, тож
вони штовхали гігантський м'яч, роль
у гігантському м'ячі та для чого ще  Наприклад,
у термінері великі команди мають три
хвилини, щоб погладити, має багато маленьких
мішків, тому це дуже незвичайні спортивні
заходи, в які можна грати або які
можна проводити під час цих спортивних і
домашніх днів в Японії, тепер давайте більш
детальні запитання, тому це завдання  для
вас
ми збираємося відповісти на ці три
запитання, давайте почнемо з номера один,
коли був перший день здоров’я та спорту
в Японії, і у нас є три можливі
відповіді: 1962 B 1964 і C 1966 Я думаю,
це легко, тому що ви маєте її
руку  дошка правильно так, правильна
відповідь: C 1966 давайте знайдемо
інформацію в тексті подивіться
японці святкують
цей день з 1966 року молодці, давайте
з реченням,
щоб мати туалет  k очно-учасники
грають a індивідуально бути у великих групах дивитись
у командах по двоє
чи пам'ятаєте ви, яка правильна
відповідь бути у великих групах давайте перевіримо
з текстом подивіться наприклад у
Тамари великі команди мають дві три
хвилини, щоб кинути якомога більше малих  мішки з квасолею
як можна більше в кошик у верхній
частині високого стовпа, тому ми маємо слово великі
команди великі схоже на великий давайте
перейдемо до номера три Коркі
це людина, яка пише текст, тому Коркі
вірить, що його батько був  Мені дуже
погано хотілося б брати участь у змаганнях, я
відчував себе погано, тому ми говоримо про
кінець тексту, коли Кокі говорив
про батьків, які брали участь у
Дні здоров’я та спорту, він сказав, що його
батько не змагався, тому що було
чому він не був дуже хворий, хотів брати
участь у змаганнях чи відчував себе погано
, ви пам’ятаєте, що він насправді не був хворий,
Кокі згадав, що в батька боліла голова,
давайте подивимося на
текст, який мій тато не брав участь у змаганнях, тому що він
мав  головний біль б  але я думаю, що це було
лише виправданням, якщо ви подивитеся на слово і
виправдання v Вірджинія, ви знаєте фразу
вибачте мене правильно, тому фраза мати
виправдання ввела в оману пар данніона, тому
його тато знайшов виправдання головний біль, який ми
не можемо перевірити  що у нього насправді
болить голова, але, ймовірно, Кокі відчув, що в
його батька насправді не
болить голова, це як би бреше.
приєднатися до вас на
цьому заході, тому що я не відчуваю себе
комфортно, це погано,
липень, добре, давайте рухатися далі, тому
зараз для вас буде завдання, і
ми збираємося створити свій власний будинок і
день спорту, тому перш за все подумайте про
це та зосередьтеся на цьому критерії, тому
назва дня аудиторія, яка збирається брати
участь діти батьки
однокласники Бо не буде шкільним
днем чи загальним днем по всій Україні подум
йте про ці речі подум
йте про конкретний день, коли ви зби
аєтесь  мати це місяці день
th  Тиждень буде субота, неділя,
понеділок, подумайте про це та про заходи,
також ви можете додати будь-яку додаткову інформацію,
яка потрібна. Я даю вам одну хвилину
подумати про це, а потім ми повернемося
і обговоримо мій день, який ми збираємося створити
разом і  ви порівнюєте зі своїм днем, тож
одна хвилина, і ми повертаємося назад
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож давайте повернемося до уроку Я сподіваюся,
що у вас є ідеї, тож давайте почнемо
з назви давайте творити разом я
не чую вас,
тому дозвольте мені  подумайте про запропоновані відповіді,
які ви можете отримати, спершу ми
збираємося намалювати малюнок ми збираємося
створити карту розуму, а потім ми збираємося
написати текст давайте почнемо з карти розуму
назва спорту a hmm health  і
спартакіада в Києві або день здоров'я та спорту у в
с Полтава Харків Одеса ох
роняє будь-які інші місця, які ви можете пр
сто назвати своє місце проживання, тому я т
т, у Києві, я буду використовувати цю
азву, то
у це  назва нашого заходу давайте
підемо з глядачами, які збираються
розлучатися  я думаю, що для дітей це
буде цікаво, але я також хочу
залучити деяких батьків до правильної практики,
це все, що дуже корисно,
час від часу робити якісь вправи
і проводити час разом зі своїми
сім’ями з дітьми, тому  Я
виберу і дітей, і їхніх батьків, тому
сім’ї, як я вже згадував, я збираюся
створити карту розуму, щоб діти, батьки та
сім’ї, як ви можете намалювати це, хто
це хлопчик чи дівчинка, щоб це були діти,
і нам потрібні батьки,
мої  малювання не так вже й красиво, і
насправді це не урок малювання,
ви можете бути просто ви можете використовувати дуже прості
малюнки, які ми прокляли, щоб робити
поцілунки з пригніченим імунітетом на кожному новому Zobrist
інформуйте нашу Co gambit rigna, щоб діти
батьки сімей, діти та дорослі  У
мене це є, і я можу зрозуміти із
зображення, так що все гаразд, давайте з
днем, хм,
коли я хочу, щоб ця подія відбулася, я
обов’язково виберу вихідні, і мені також
подобається, коли там сонячна погода, і
ви можете легко розслабитися.  у нього тепла погода,
так щось схоже на вересень і травень,
так що давайте виберемо так, давайте робити це
двічі на рік двічі на рік, значить, два
рази, тому спочатку вересень, а потім
травень, початок і кінець
навчального року, академічний так, вересень і
я  і я також хочу згадати вихідні,
давайте провести тут вихідні, це
важливо, тому в суботу чи неділю давайте
намалюємо малюнок,
щоб це було схоже на календар, я
напишу тут ці цифри дев'ять і
номер п'ять, що означає
число дев'ять, число вересня  п'ять травня,
молодці, і я хочу зазначити, що це
мають бути вихідні вихідні, це два
останні дні тижня, субота або неділя,
тож дозвольте мені розфарбувати це таким чином 1 2 3 4 5
це 6 і 7 ви пам'ятаєте всі
дні  тижні давайте переглянемо понеділок
вівторок середа четвер п'ятниця
субота та неділя добре зроблено, чи
можете ви зрозуміти із зображення
інформацію, щоб у нас були місяці вересень,
можливо, у нас були вихідні, чого не вистачає
Браво
двічі на рік, тому я  якщо зробити
це двічі, а насправді з цієї косої риски
означає, що, ймовірно, вересень або травень, щоб
ми могли змінити його на кому замість
косої риски, ми маємо кому вересень і травень
добре, давайте перейдемо до діяльності,
це найцікавіша частина, тож що ми
Я хотів би мати книгу про змагання
між дітьми та дорослими,
батьки, тож, ймовірно, хлопчики і дівчатка грають
проти своїх мам і тат, це
буде цікаво, або ми можемо розділити це
змагання на дві окремі частини
конкурс хлопчиків, тож хлопчики та їхні
тата та змагання жінок, як чоловіки
та жінки, дівчата, їхні дівчата та
їхні мами, то що
для вас найцікавіше, змішані команди чи
окремі.
брати участь  g, щоб повторити малюнки
діти проти дорослих добре, тому у мене змішані
команди, якщо ви думаєте, що змішані команди
не є гарною ідеєю, краще грати
окремими командами, тому, ймовірно, ви будете малювати
лише хлопчиків проти їхніх татів чи дівчат
проти їхніх мам, добре, якщо ви  не
думайте, що мати дорослих – це гарна ідея,
тож просто згадайте інформацію,
наприклад, хлопчики проти дівчат, це також
можливо, давайте йти далі, щоб у нас був
футбол, у що ще ми можемо грати Мені
подобається ідея з японського дня спорту,
це як катання  величезні кулі,
звичайно, нам потрібен час, щоб
створити ці величезні кулі, але це
дуже приємне заняття, це дуже
цікаво, це так весело, тому давайте
назвемо це, гм, кульковий ролик, давайте будемо
таким, добре, давайте намалюємо його величезну кулю і  у нас
є маленькі діти та маленькі батьки,
які штовхають бейсбол своїми
руками, вони намагаються катати його величезними
м'ячами, добре, я вже бачу, як ці люди
намагаються катати ці величезні м'ячі, це
буде так весело,
що ще хм футб  все, що у нас є кульковий
ролик, і це цікава йога,
мабуть або ймовірно, якщо ми думаємо про
підводне плавання з маскою, я люблю снорклінг, але,
на жаль, ми не можемо мати його
скрізь, а про воду може бути холодно
у вересні в травні, я кажу, що я б припустив,
що у нас є  підводне плавання з маскою, біг, що це
таке, тому ви насправді одягнені як підводний
плавання, ви носите ласти, ви
можете носити гідрокостюм,
але це не обов'язково, що
потрібно, це ласти окуляри, трубка
і, ймовірно, кільце для плавання, і ви намагаєтеся
бігти в цьому спорядженні
це також буде дуже весело, тож давайте
використовувати це
підводне плавання, біг або підводне плавання,
давайте змінимо це на підводне плавання з маскою, добре,
так давайте намалюємо це буде
цікаво, тому людині, яка носить
окуляри
та трубку, я скажу людину  він
одягнений у ласти та кільце для плавання,
а людині потрібно бігти
дуже швидко, тому моє зображення буде
таким, це смішно. Вибачте, я не
вчитель малювання, але ви можете зрозуміти
окуляри  кільце для плавання з трубкою і ласти,
і ми не на воді, тому, як ви
бачите, ми на землі, тому
я хочу використовувати ці види діяльності,
тому, як бачите, у мене є додатковий рядок,
це означає, що ви можете додати будь-яку важливу
інформацію до  мій проект Я хочу додати,
що це вільний день, вам не потрібно
нічого платити, щоб брати участь у цих
змаганнях, тож давайте напишемо це так, щоб ми
написали слово безкоштовно, що означає без грошей,
вам не потрібно купувати
квитки вам  не потрібно нічого платити,
і вони також хотіли б згадати,
оскільки це буде довгий день з
усіма цими заходами, тому їжа включена,
їжа включена, або ви також можете дозволити своїм
родинам влаштувати барбекю, маленькі
пікніки, будьте обережні з цим,
якщо ви  згадане барбекю, це означає, що
ви дозволяєте сім'ям розводити багаття, я
б не сказав, що це гарна
ідея, тому, ймовірно, пікнік краще,
пікнік означає, що у вас є килимок і ви
сідаєте і випиваєте свої бутерброди або
закуски  соку трохи ват
з’їжте кілька яблук і бананів, щоб це був пікнік,
але без вогню, тому це день здоров’я, і
це дуже безпечно, це не повинно бути небезпечним,
тому наша ментальна карта готова, тому ми маємо
всю важливу інформацію,
ми маємо назву, аудиторію, яку ми маємо
дата діяльності та
необхідна інформація, яку нам потрібно написати,
щоб описати проект, тому сформулюйте
все словами, щоб це було
текстом, щоб це було домашнім завданням,
і ви також можете надіслати свої проекти
мені безпосередньо,
щоб тепер ви могли  дивіться мою адресу електронної пошти
на екрані,
це Наталія, не навчайся онлайн на
gmail.com, ти можеш надіслати мені свої ментальні карти
зі згаданими словами, тому що
з фотографій ти не
все розумієш, або можеш надіслати
мені цілі тексти та  Я збираюся перевірити
це та згадати це на наших уроках, тому
знову домашнє завдання напишіть текст або
завершите проект про те, як
сонячна пляма залишається на вашому місці, і я чую,
як дзвінок дзвонить поетапно, нам потрібно
припинити урок, дуже дякую до
побачення-  до побачення
[Му  sic]
ти